Mes amis,
j'ai oublié de vous dire quelque chose.
Non, je ne paye pas l'apéro
parce que vous êtes très nombreux.
Mais
attendez, je vais me rattraper
car avant d'entonner notre hymne national,
je voudrais vous annoncer 1 petite surprise,
je dois vous faire 1 révélation,
je ne suis pas,
je ne suis pas
le dernier orateur de ce meeting
et avant l'apéro,
la soirée n'est pas terminée.
1 personne
que je crois beaucoup connaissent ici dans cette salle,
a tenu à être présente en Moselle ce soir
pour nous apporter,
pour nous apporter son soutien
et surtout, je le pense, à vous dire elle aussi
à quel point rien n'est jamais fini pour la France.
Cette personne, mes amis,
cette personne, mes amis,
est 1 personne
qui compte beaucoup pour moi, y compris sur le plan
personnel.
C'est 1 personne sans qui,
à dire vrai, je ne serai pas devant vous ce soir.
Je lui dois beaucoup
son soutien mes chers,
elle tient à vous dire quelques mots ce soir
et je vous demande, mes amis,
de l'écouter
et de l'accueillir avec l'enthousiasme qu'elle mérite.
Je la remercie,
cette personne,
sincèrement,
d'être parmi nous ce soir.
Nous lui devons beaucoup
et je lui cède immédiatement la parole